foreign
hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear yes I finally got around to seeing
this uh so I'd been noticing a lot of
interest and Buzz uh surrounding this
movie which of course came out in 2022
and is called Barbarian now this movie
actually premiered at the San Diego
Comic-Con last summer I think it was
like Late July but I wasn't entirely
sure like what the nature of the buzz
was and to be honest I was kind of
hoping that I could keep it that way
because as I've mentioned many times on
this channel uh I really like to go into
all movies not just this one uh knowing
as little about them as possible now I
did have a couple of friends a couple of
you guys out there did recommend that I
see it but didn't give me any specifics
thankfully and I have to say that in the
case of Barbarian I'm really really glad
that I was successfully able to avoid
seeing any reviews or any spoilers or
anything about like anyone's opinion or
about the movie or anything like that
before going in to watch it because does
as pretty much every reviewer like after
I saw it like I went and read other
other reviews and like watched other
people's videos about it and every every
single one of them says this movie is
way way better if you go into it having
no idea like what you're in for and I'm
gonna add my opinion about that to the
pile this is absolutely way way better
way better like one of these movies if
you have no idea what's gonna happen
because I didn't and it was just it was
fun time and I'm gonna say like right
here from the jump uh even though I'm
not gonna spoil the movie outright uh
because you know it's still actually
playing in some theaters after all this
time uh and it only recently arrived on
HBO Max which is where I watched it
um so I understand that not everyone has
had a chance to see it yet because
Christ look how long it took me to see
it I'm gonna try and discuss it in a way
that isn't like to explicitly spoilery
but I might still kind of like reveal
some plot details that it would probably
be like more fun for you not to know
beforehand
and as I said I'm going to reiterate I
strongly strongly recommend that you go
into this film with this little
foreknowledge as you can manage but on
the other hand uh in order to talk about
the movie to any like degree of depth or
talk about what I some of the things I
liked about it some aspects of the plot
might be like inadvertently exposed like
I said I'm not gonna I'm not gonna spoil
it outright or like say exactly where it
goes because you know I don't want to do
that because it's like really new but
I'm just saying that I might reveal some
stuff that you would rather like not
know ahead of time so you know please
listen or beware now incredibly
mind-blowingly Barbarian is actually the
product of a first time feature writer
director whose name is Zach kreger and
his kind of previous claim to fame was
as one of three founding members three
guys in a comedy troupe from New York
City uh called the whitest guys you know
I haven't seen any of their stuff so I
don't know if I've heard it's funny but
I don't uh I don't know now while it is
in our now it's inarguably true that uh
comedy and horror are explicitly linked
I mean just kind of like they're kind of
like you know two sides of the same coin
pretty much because they both have to do
with setup and payoff like in particular
ways and of evoking like a strong
reaction so even though I know that
um it always surprises me and I don't
know why it does but it always surprised
me that when someone who is like really
into comedy and stuff like that it turns
out to be really really good at horror I
mean the same thing happened with Jordan
peel and I was surprised in that case
too and I don't know why I was
um but this one really surprised me
because like I said I didn't know like
the guy's comedic stuff like beforehand
but the fact that he could come out and
make a horror movie this assured this
confident like his first time around is
crazy to me and that's just like it's
that's amazing it's I love when that
happens I mean and the thing about this
movie too
is that it really um I mean it's it's
almost like masterful just the way that
the humor and the horror is like
intermingled like to the great
enhancement of both
um I mean you know a lot of horror films
try to add humor to sort of lighten up
or to complement the more kind of like
scary or ghastly elements of the story
but I find that not really that many
succeed in finding that perfect balance
but I think Barbarian gets it exactly
right which is really kind of like a
Herculean feat in itself I guess now
that's not to say that Barbarian is a
horror comedy it absolutely is not uh
it's it's very very far from that so
please don't get that impression uh in
fact the movie is actually very very
tense very suspenseful it's actually
scary in parts and it also is very very
gruesome in places though in other
places it knows like when to pull back
and when to be restrained uh again like
a very very great balance
um but it also knows that there are
times when humor is called for and there
are times when details of the plot kind
of maybe skirt the boundaries of
believability a little bit and the movie
kind of very admirably like leans into
this and it's just like a fantastic
effect all around so in short in case
you couldn't tell uh Barbarian is easily
one of the best horror movies I've seen
in a long time and it did something that
a lot of horror movies can't or won't do
it actually surprised me like it
challenged my expectations it went in
directions that I couldn't foresee which
is really something in itself because
you know I've watched horror movies my
whole life you pretty much know the
drill you know how it's gonna go but
this one not at all not at all uh it
wasn't um afraid to subvert storytelling
norms and it would kind of trusted its
audience to like keep up it didn't
handhold you or anything like that which
I thought was really cool uh it was just
refreshing and fun and it's just like
it's completely Bonkers
um a wild ride that literally had me on
the edge of my chair the whole time
wondering what exactly the [ __ ] was
going on you know what I mean like I had
no idea it kind of it gave me vaguely
the same sort of feeling as you know
James Wan's recent film malignant just
in terms of sheer audacity I guess
though Barbarian is like way way way
better than that movie you know what I
mean that one was like real audacious
and stuff but it was kind of I don't
know that one was Bonkers this one's
Bonkers but in a slightly different way
but in a way that's also sort of similar
like if that makes any sense yeah
because this movie again is batshit
insane but in the best possible way and
at heart too it actually like had quite
a bit to say but it didn't really hit
you over the head with its theming like
you didn't really have to you know take
from it if you wanted to but it was
there if you wanted to take it I mean it
still remembered to be just like this
entertaining unpredictable actually
frightening and also like blackly comic
Movie experience you know what I mean
like it remembered to be all of that now
I can't really tell you um how happy I
am that this movie kind of came out of
nowhere a little bit and was this good
and that it turned out to be like a
sleeper hit I think it only cost like
four or five million dollars to make and
ended up making like several times that
back because Barbarian in case you
didn't know was actually released by a
major Studio 20th century Studios matter
of fact and that kind of like and the
fact that it was successful gives me
hope that we'll maybe see some more like
interesting real ballsy horror films
like this from new and untested talent I
mean you know you hear that Hollywood
more like this please like this was
really really good so anyway I mean the
synopsis and the trailer of this film
which I watched the trailer after I saw
the movie I don't usually watch trailers
unless I happen to see them like if I'm
at the movie theater or anything like
that but I don't usually seek them out
because like I said I like going into
things completely blind
um but I did watch the trailer afterward
because I was curious as to how they
marketed it so the synopsis in the
trailer they very deliberately kept them
vague so that audiences audiences
wouldn't um quite know what to expect
when they sat down to watch it and that
was absolutely the right move as I
mentioned basically all the description
says is that this is a story about a
woman who rents an Airbnb finds out
there's already a guy staying there and
then decides to spend the night anyway
but finds out that there's a lot more
going on than just like a strange dude
in her rental house
now this is an accurate depiction of the
First Act of the film but after that
point uh it takes several drastic turns
and watching it I mean I absolutely
loved the experience of having no idea
like where this movie was taking me then
and for a while like I was initially
trying to guess what was happening I'm
like oh it's gonna be like this how much
you want to bet blah blah but after a
couple times of doing that and getting
it wrong I just kind of like was like
Jenny why are you trying to guess just
like chill out and let this let the
story go where it's gonna go and let it
take you on this peculiar Journey that
it's on and once I kind of like got into
that I was just like yeah this is good
I'm just gonna let it take me on a ride
and I suggest that that's the way that
you watch it because if you try to guess
where it's going you're probably not
gonna guess so Georgina Campbell is in
this and she is phenomenal uh she plays
kind of one of the main characters Tess
and she's this young woman who has come
to Detroit
for a job interview with a like a local
Indie filmmaker now she arrives at her
Airbnb which she has booked in the
middle of a stormy night and in spite of
the instructions from the property
management company which she gets texted
to her she finds that the key isn't in
the lock box where it's supposed to be
so she then discovers much to her
Chagrin and annoyance that there's a man
named Keith played by Bill Skarsgard in
a very ingenious bit of casting which if
you've seen the movie you'll know why
that is uh he's already staying in the
house and he insisted that he's like
look I paid to rent this place like for
this date too and it's like they're
trying to comparing each other's
bookings and stuff like that uh long
story short it turns out that she rented
through Airbnb he rented through
HomeAway like a different app and
apparently the house was double booked
Now Keith actually like invites her in
while she tries to get everything sorted
out like to find another place to stay
or whatever but of course I mean she
doesn't know this guy from Adam right I
mean it it appears as though all of this
was an honest mistake you know [ __ ] does
happen but who's to know for sure really
I mean this guy could for example he
could just be squatting here or maybe he
owns the place and this is like a setup
he does like to lure people into his
house or something like that I mean the
guy seems okay okay but he's a little
bit awkward and he's also played by
Pennywise so you know what I mean so
we're inclined to be like a little
suspicious of this fellow so I mean this
whole First Act is like amazingly
amazingly suspenseful I mean it's
beautifully shot it's very very eerie
It's very effective I mean the whole
time like I said it's just really really
tense like Tess is on a Razor's Edge I
mean she's just unsure like should I
trust this man I'm kind of stuck you
know she calls around there's no other
hotels like available because there's a
convention in town or something like
that so she's kind of stuck there and
one thing that actually really resonated
with me that she says like a little bit
later on is that had the situation here
been reversed like in other words had
she already been in the house and then
this strange dude like turned up on her
doorstep late claiming there was a
mix-up or whatever there would have been
absolutely no way that she would have
invited the man inside and like much
less let him crash there and I mean
rightfully so you'd kind of be dumb to
do that but she points out she's like
well Keith the man he didn't even like
hesitate at all like to let her in
because he didn't feel like he had
anything to fear from her and that
scenario is absolutely not the same way
the other way around and this fact is
um something that the story utilizes uh
with much deviousness which is as far as
I'll go so I mean like the conversations
and the interactions that they have in
this whole First Act are just like
really really outstanding build up I
mean Tess is kind of like feeling out
the whole deal you know like I said he's
kind of like saying kind of the right
things but he's also like a little bit
awkward so you're not really sure like
what his deal is and stuff I mean she's
cut and Tess is kind of wondering have I
just made the stupidest decision in my
whole life am I about to get murdered or
whatever now eventually like she does
let her guard down just a little bit
um and she even tells Keith about a
tendency to keep going back to her
controlling boyfriend even though she
knows that she shouldn't and this is a
personality trait that will absolutely
like play out into the story like going
forward which again that's as far as I'm
gonna go on that now she actually like
they have kind of a pleasant evening she
bids Keith good night and it seems like
everything is gonna be all right you
know what I mean like it's not as bad as
she was like fearing but then she's
awakened in the middle of the night by a
weird noise and she discovers that her
bedroom door which she very explicitly
like closed before she went to sleep is
now open now obviously she thinks that
the worst has happened and her
suspicions about Keith were absolutely
correct but when she goes out in the
living room she finds that he's like
asleep on the couch and he's kind of
seemingly like in the middle of a
nightmare like he's talking to sleep and
everything like that now she wakes him
up and he seems to genuinely have no
idea like what she's talking about it's
like I've been sleeping here the whole
time and then we see in the background
that the door to presumably the basement
appears to close by itself so at this
point you're wondering like what the
[ __ ] is going on in this house is there
someone else in here like is it haunted
like what the [ __ ] you know what I mean
it's there's like lots of scenarios that
are like playing out in your mind so as
the First Act goes on on Tess ends up
getting trapped down in the basement
like she has to go down there like to
get extra toilet paper and the door ends
up like closing and locking behind her
now while she's down in the basement
um which like I said isn't really a
spoiler because they kind of show a
little bit of that on the poster uh she
ends up finding some pretty sketchy ass
[ __ ] uh that nobody would want to find
in the basement of a house that they're
staying in you know that's all I'm going
to say about that uh and from there like
more events uh unfold that I won't spoil
but after this bit like the first act
with the two of them like plays out
there's actually a hard cut to what
seems like At first a completely
different movie and this movie is
starring Justin Long uh who I love he
was great in Tusk and he was in Jeepers
Creepers too uh but it starts Justin
long as a very cocky very Carefree actor
in Los Angeles and he's tooling around
in a convertible on a sunny day and
you're asking yourself what does this
have to do with the initial story which
was concerning Tess and Keith uh why and
why in fact do Tess and Keith disappear
essentially for the next third the next
section of the movie and to that I will
say just be patient because it will all
come together in time as will some other
seemingly unrelated kind of
interstitials uh featuring Richard break
being very very creepy as he's very very
good at I mean from a plotting and
screen writing standpoint this is like a
master class it absolutely does not
follow like the try tried and true
conventions of filmmaking or
storytelling which is one of the reasons
that nobody wanted to make it initially
hell I think even a24 like passed on it
but that's one of the reasons that I
found it so compelling it wasn't more of
the same it was doing something
different and it still kept you engaged
the whole time because you're trying to
like figure out what's happening and how
everything is connected
um I have to say too that all the acting
here is great the casting here is
brilliant and it essentially uses both
Bill skarsgard's and Justin Long's like
previous on-screen roles and their kind
of perceived personas as both shorthand
and misdirection and again that's all
I'm going to say about that
uh cinematography also outstanding and
it was doing a lot of the heavy lifting
in terms of like visual storytelling
particularly in its really interesting
and sometimes unconventional use of
light and Shadow like one example I'll
give of that is that usually uh in
horror movies specifically like you know
bad [ __ ] happens when it's like dark
outside which it doesn't this one too
but I thought an interesting subversion
of that was that when she first arrives
at the Airbnb which like I said is in
Detroit it's dark and she can't really
see like the neighborhood of it she's
heard that it's like a sketchy
neighborhood or whatever this house is
like the nice house and on the block or
whatever but she's heard that it's a
sketchy neighbor she can't really see it
because it's dark and there's a great
thing where she like kind of goes out
the next day when she's on the way to
her job interview and she sees the
neighborhood that she's been staying in
like in the daylight and it looks like
you can imagine it looks like an
abandoned [ __ ] neighborhood in
Detroit and the fact that they use the
light in that way like in a subversive
kind of way because usually like in a
horror movie when something's light it's
like oh it's happier it's better and
stuff like that but in this case like
light made everything worse and I
thought that was like a really
interesting like subversion of the light
and Shadow Dynamic but that's kind of
the only example I'm gonna give because
that happened like fairly early in the
movie I mean I personally found no
particular flaw with this film and
matter of fact I loved it so much that
I'm already anticipating a second watch
because I want to like pick up on some
stuff that I probably missed the first
time around now I did see a couple of
reviewers who While most reviewers I've
seen like absolutely loved this and I'm
totally on board with that
um but a couple of them did bring up a
minor criticism that they thought the
characters made some dumb decisions that
maybe real people wouldn't make uh if
confronted with the same circumstances
now I can see where they're coming from
on that but honestly I didn't find
anything here that was particularly
egregious in that regard I mean for one
thing people do dumb things in horror
movies sometimes I mean [ __ ] they even
have like a whole like spoof like Geico
commercial about it for Christ's sake
let's go hide behind the chainsaws uh
you know kind of stuff like that and to
be honest as horror fans we usually let
that slide because you know honestly
nothing would happen in a horror movie
if somebody didn't go down and explore
the creepy basement or the woods or
whatever but I mean even aside from that
kind of glib excuse for justification I
also felt that Barbarian in particular
um was very careful in setting up the
characters Personalities in such a way
that their behavior made sense in
context so the decisions that they made
like came across as believable and
organic to me I mean maybe they aren't
necessarily the decisions that I would
have made in other words but other
people aren't me uh and the way that the
character of Tess in particular uh was
set up or was delineated acted in ways
that maybe I wouldn't have but were
still understandable from the
perspective of her own own values and
attributes and things like that she
acted in character in other words so if
this all sounds kind of vague uh I do
apologize for that but I'm also doing
that deliberately because if you haven't
seen Barbarian I want you to be able to
experience the same kind of crazy ride
that I went on with this movie when I
watched it I get that it's not going to
be to everyone's taste it does seem to
be getting like overwhelmingly positive
reviews which I totally see but again
there's always going to be some people
that aren't going to love it for
whatever reason and that's fair that's
fine too you know some people might not
for example like the really hard plot
twists that this takes or doesn't or
might not like like not knowing where
it's going like maybe some people would
want to know what to expect and stuff
like that and this one is not a movie
that you want to watch if you just want
like something traditional that you kind
of know what's coming and everything but
I mean for me like as a lifelong horror
fan I always kind of like love and
cherish the times when I come across
something like this something that
engages is me as much as this movie did
that kind of like keeps me on my toes
the whole time and shows me something
surprising
um you know what I mean I'm not saying
this movie like reinvented the wheel or
anything like that but it just went in
ways that you didn't expect and that's
really really refreshing and it's you
don't see it that much in horror anymore
I mean if indeed you ever really saw it
because like I said horror has you know
genre conventions just like everything
else does so it's kind of cool when you
see something that does something that
you're not expecting the only thing only
regret I wish that I had got off my lazy
ass and gone to see it in the theater
because I've heard that it's an even
more fun time like seeing it with an
audience which I totally get like now
that I've seen the movie I'm like yeah
this would have been like a lot of fun
like seeing it with other people like
reacting to it but I mean even just
watching it by myself I had a total
total blast with it and um you know I
would absolutely unreservably
unreservedly recommend it like I said
not everyone's gonna love it but it does
seem like most people uh that I reviewed
like really really liked it and I can
totally see that because I really really
loved this I thought it was great so I'm
really looking forward to what this
writer director does next because man if
this was his first thing then that's uh
that's pretty awesome you know what I
mean so it's been a good year for horror
matter of fact now that I think about it
and that'll do it for this flickers of
fear thanks you guys for watching
Remember to like the video I always
forget to say that but I'll see you guys
again on the next one bye